For sure. We got some good questions. So Matthew says, is it viable to try and snatch a few leads
from FBA groups to use also to close deals before ads take off? I remember you did talk
about this. It's pretty hit or miss, but can work. Francesca, what are your thoughts on it?
Did you know what he's asking? You cut out the first half. Is it viable to take,
go into Facebook groups, grab a few free leads and use those to go hook a deal and
get the process going while you're waiting for ads?
Can you repeat it? Sorry. No, you're good. So like, and the, like Facebook groups,
people ask for recommendations like, Hey, who has a local concrete guy, right? Can we use those
leads, those interested people as a form of free leads on our end to give to business owners
while we're waiting for ads to take off or even to supplement them to get the deal?
I think so. Yeah. Nick, you did a live on this or YouTube video like last year.
The only thing I like to use Facebook group leads to pick up the slack. I don't like to use
them to start a deal. Sometimes I'll use them to hook a deal to test the market. I don't love,
once I know the market's good to use them, because then if my ads don't kick in, it's like,
I don't have a predictable way to continually just scrape leads. But if I'm running ads and
my ads slow down, it's a great way to go get like some sweat equity deals and go get some
leads that way. So my opinion is hook them, use those leads to get interest, to gauge interest,
to call around, to get somebody on the hook if you need to, if you want to do that without
setting up ads. But I like to have my leads coming in from ads and then use those as a supplement
rather than my main thing, because I don't, I can't predict when people are going to ask
for recommendations, right? So that's just my two cents, but leads are leads guys. It's about
strategy versus tactic. The strategy is giving free leads in advance. The tactic that we're using
is Google ads. But guess what? If you guys can, if somebody in this group can come up with a
predictable, you know, repeatable way to glean and harvest leads out of Facebook groups forever,
and we don't have to run ads, go ahead and hit me up on DMs. And we'll go ahead and implement
that and stop running ads, but ads is just the most predictable thing.